you
hi my name is Nikhil Rao and I am with
10x genomics and I am the commercial
lead for the vision spatial gene
expression platform here at 10x genomics
today I'm hoping to convey the
importance of why spatial information
with gene expression is important and
also help you understand what is the
product that we are in the middle of
launching and hopefully give you an idea
of what that could do for your science
so we always like to start with this
first slide which is a quote from David
Craig out of USC which says everyone is
waiting for spatial without context you
can only learn so much we think that
this is rather important because of 10x
we have been really the leader it's
single celled gene expression and single
cell assays which tells you the what -
what's going on in a single cell but we
believe that this new technology can
tell you be where - where genes are
expressed on tissue samples that are
really important to understanding the
biology that you're interested in and we
think that there are a lot of groups and
researchers really waiting for this
technology so we're really excited to
start talking about it today so why
would you want to do what we call
spatial analysis and what is spatial
analysis now spatial is essentially
overlaying gene expression on to an HD
image there is the ability to basically
section tissues and then look at gene
expression globally within that tissue
and localize it to areas that you might
be interested in what this does is it
allows you to do gene expression without
any kind of tissue dissociation so in
previous methods require you to RNA
isolate out of the tissue which means
that you lose the integrity of the
tissue and you don't know which RNA
molecule came from what area of the
tissue so you're still able to retain
the organization and tissue of the
cellular microenvironment but it also
provides a way to look at cell types in
the context of heterogeneous tissue
based on gene expression so you can
identify cells based on whatever genes
are expressed in the cell
and understand where they're co-located
within the tissue and in this example
here you can see I'm a pathologist has
actually annotated a region of this
tissue as cancerous and in in the
subsequent panel it's in the fluorescent
channel on the right you can see that we
use spatial here in this publication to
detect the lymphocytes or the white
blood cells that are really infiltrating
the tumor and the pathologists looked at
that spatial information said yes this
is yielding a good prognosis because the
tumor has a positive immune response
indeed
the similar sort of annotation has been
made by a pathologist where they say Oh
in this region there's cancer but if you
look at the spatial gene expression
signature for lymphocytes you can see
that the immune cells are blocked from
entering that cancer so it gives you an
extra layer of information that you
wouldn't have been able to achieve with
other technology methods and this was
deemed a poor prognosis because of the
fact that you are not seeing a positive
immune response now you might say you
might be able to do this with
immunohistochemistry or other types of
technologies but the reality is that
there are not an extensive number of
markers that identify every cell type of
interest you may not know what cell
types you need to be looking for and our
spatial platform allows you to look
without sort of a bias view at
everything that exists in the in the
tissue section based off of all the
mRNAs in in the cells that exist in the
tissue so we believe that spatial has a
place in most areas of biology and that
ranges from oncology which is sort of
the example that I just gave you really
really important for tumor heterogeneity
tumor microenvironment and white blood
cell migration as well as immunology
understanding immune populations what
are the types of immune cells is it an
m1 and 2 response all the way into
developmental biology from mapping
specific organs as well as understanding
development as a function of time and
space which is really
kind of an emerging field it also has a
lot of applications and tissue
engineering and wound healing followed
by neuroscience in which groups are very
interested in understanding the anatomy
of the brain and studying
neurodegenerative diseases and we also
call out pathology here even though it's
not really a research area it is
certainly a technique and a field in
which a certain standard has been
generated over the last year's to study
these types of research areas and tissue
sections but we think that this could
enable pathology to do more than what
it's done before to provide an
orthogonal method by which they are able
to diagnose patients as well as treat
patients based off of gene expression
not just morphology
so now I'll kind of transition to know
what is the product that we are talking
about today and how is that going to
help your research so we have something
called visi 'm which is a platform that
is sort of parallel to other platform
called the chromium
however Vizia ms not an instrument it is
a technology that we're using called the
spatial gene expression solution that
essentially allows you to look at
unbiased as we call unbiased meaning
looking at all the mRNAs that exist in
the transcriptome and high-throughput
gene expression analysis for intact
tissue sections from a wide variety of
sample types and we'll talk more about
what those sample types are but you can
look at the biological architecture in
normal versus disease you can look for
new biomarkers and specific cell types
and regions within the tissue but the
big two bullet points that I like to hit
here is that it really does integrate
easily with current laboratory methods
and tools so again we're not selling or
providing an instrument we are providing
an assay that is really built such that
it works with the infrastructure that
you might already be familiar with or
exists in the institution that you
likely work in and we'll get to what
that infrastructure looks like and the
last point is that this is really a 1.1
day end to end workflow from the minute
you section your tissue to getting a
final library ready for sequencing can
be done easily within one day
and in general we use slides as well as
reagents here to provide you all that
has the ability to look at very much
sort of a high sensitivity assay that
interrogate thousands of genes detected
per spot and we'll talk about what the
spot looks like the resolution is
extremely high with 5000 spots per
capture area this is where you place the
tissue section on the slide and the
spots represent the captures of the mRNA
molecules onto the slide each spot is 55
microns in diameter and we have a very
close packing of the spots again
everything is unbiased so the poly a
base capture method it's efficient the
one-day workflow time all the slides and
really reagents really important for our
kids are included and in general we see
that our cell resolution is anywhere
from one to ten cells per spot meaning
that for one to ten cells we're able to
look at that regional gene expression
that's sort of an average of those cells
so depending on the tissue type you
might have one cell that gets
interrogated you're basically getting
single cell resolution of gene
expression but if a tissue is has a lot
of dense cells closely packed to one
another you might get upwards of ten
cells per spot that kind of averaged out
the gene expression in that area in any
case you get to really get a holistic
picture of what's going on within the
tissue and I'll show you that via data
and images in the next few slides so you
might have seen that we've had a
technology that is existed on the
marketplace to date and that's the
spatial transcriptomics technology that
is a really a company that 10x had
acquired last year and this technology
was an incredibly impactful to the field
and this consisted again of these spots
that are on a glass slide where you put
your tissue section in here you can see
an image of a mouse olfactory bulb in
which the olfactory bulb was placed onto
the the capture area and you can
actually see anatomical features
based on the heat map that is showing
the unique molecular identifiers or the
number of molecules picked up in that
generalized region since that technology
has been out on the market we at 10x
have done a great deal of work to
simplify the workflow and also improve
the performance and you can see now with
our new vision spatial gene expression
platform that the resolution the density
of the spots as well as the ability to
identify anatomical features in this
mouthal Packard bulb has greatly
improved and you can see there that we
now see about 80,000 um is vs. 14 so
we've really improved the sensitivity of
the assay dramatically
so what does this workflow look like at
a high level you we have some sample
prep steps that involve sectioning
tissue on to the slide we then will take
this slide once the tissues are on
through to H&E so you actually stain the
section then you can image in bright
field we ask you to essentially take a
stitched image of the entire capture
area which are those four boxes there to
save for later as a tiff or JPEG then
you would take the slide and do an RNA
isolation followed by T DNA synthesis
and library construction and run on a
sequencer once the sequencing is
finished we import the sequencing data
along with the image of that was taken
from the slide into our data
visualization tool to allow you to pair
gene expression with the image analysis
so there's a lot of various steps
involved in the workflow and we'll get
into detail what those look like
looking at the slide itself I mentioned
that there are four capture areas on the
slide each of those areas has the 5000
bar-coded spots that are at a hundred
micron center-to-center distance and
then each of those spots contains
millions of ala ghosts or barcodes that
you can see on the right that have a
partial read one for sequencing a
spatial barcode which is essentially a
sequence that allows you and sequencing
to understand where the molecule came
from on the slide so instead of in our
single cell assays which will have a
cell barcode that will relate all the
sequencing data to a specific cell in
this case we have a spot barcode or
spatial barcode that relates all the
sequencing data to a place on the slide
um I which is a unique molecular
identifier again which basically counts
the number of molecules and a poly DT
which captures the mRNA
and you can see here a blow-up of one of
those capture areas and it is a square
shape that in the black regions contains
all of these bar coded spots and that is
a six point five by six point five
millimeter square area and on the
outside of that you can see these red
dots and what these red dots are is what
we call a fiducial frame what that is is
a larger dots that don't contain any
kind of spatial information nor do they
pick up RNA but they're using image
registration so that when you take the
image and you pair the sequencing data
on top the sequencing data basically
finds its way to the right spot on the
slide based off of where the image is
taken and how those fiducials show up in
image analysis so it's basically guiding
the sequencing data to the right guide
posts so that it Maps perfectly onto the
slide and so it all it is is a way for
us to very accurately map the gene
expression data on to the image data so
now you can see we have sort of a more
granular workflow here where again you
would use a cryo stat to section the a
tissue block onto the slide then you
would stain an image so you would do an
H and E staining followed by imaging and
then you would permeable eyes the tissue
such that the mRNA is fall out of the
tissue onto the ala go DT convert the
RNA to cDNA on the slide and then at
that point you can take everything off
the slide and put them into tubes and do
sort of PCR based library prep for
sequencing
so the kits that we provide are the
tissue optimization slide reagent kit as
well as gene expression slide and
reagent kit now I mention that there is
a step where we permeable eyes the
tissue now for every tissue you might
have a various degree of
permeabilization you can imagine that
some dense tissues might take more times
i per me lies some that are more a
cellular or maybe less nice
extracellular matrix heavy are actually
easy to permeable eyes so we give you a
kit that allows you to for any
individual tissue optimize those
conditions this is that tissue
optimization kit in which you have these
eight capture areas here as the image
shows but they don't include any spatial
information it is purely to optimize the
tissue optimization once you understand
and can isolate the maximal amount of
mrna based on a specific condition for
permeabilization you take that condition
into the next kit for the spatial gene
expression slidin region kid so in this
kit this is where all the spatial
analysis happens and you're able to pair
the gene expression with the image data
so really the tissue optimization kick
we see being used as sort of a one-time
use for any given pitch hype and once
you really find that optimal condition
you just use the gene expression slide
reagent kit up from them there on out
for given study
we've tested a large number of tissues
internally under them ranging from human
mouse rat and a previous iterations
plants and insects of also showing proof
of concept to work these tissues haven't
seen any issue with testing them there's
no limitation and we believe that these
tissues internally the leafless would
and continue to grow this is not an
all-inclusive list as we just haven't
had the bandwidth to test every tissue
out there but we have planned on cutting
a large number of tissues in the near
future
and our software is such that it's
license free and it's very similar to
what we provided with our single cell
portfolio which is a software called you
might be familiar with cell Ranger for
spatial amounts we deem it safe space
Ranger as well as loop browser for our
image analysis so again providing
automated image processing and
interactive data visualization tools to
kind of be able to use as if you had no
kind of software expertise it's actually
very straightforward to use even if
you're not a bioinformatician and with
these two software tools you can really
do a lot of different analyses that will
kind of go into detail on but in in an
example that we like to show just to
compare with single cell is that you can
look at an unbiased t-sne plot based off
of gene expression and look at the
clustering of these cells based off that
gene expression and then annotate
directly back on to the image so that
you can see where those cell clusters
fit onto the onto the slide so you're
taking things that are based on genes
and space and putting them into a
location on sort of an H&E map
so show you some applications of how
this is used and really kind of
specifically talk about the mouse brain
the mouse brain is something we've done
a lot of internal work on primarily
because it's really easy to see the
anatomy via H and E but also has a
really diverse set of cell types that
cluster really nicely together based on
the anatomy alone so you can see an A we
have an H and E of a mouse brain and
then B we've done spatial and ask the
software to tell us how many unique
molecular identifiers exist in the
region of that hme and you can see that
in certain areas there are more um eyes
picked up than in others and then we ask
the question of how many genes unique
genes are identified in any given
location you can see in the sections
here that there's a lot more gene sort
of on the periphery of this tissue than
in the center and then you can go
further to say okay knowing that there
are different levels of genes and each
of these cells can we create populations
of cells that are very similar to one
another based on gene expression and
this is sort of in the previous slide
what I showed with the
TSN a plot but mapped on to the actual
HM slides you can see here we had eight
clusters and then you can even go
further and say hey I am interested in
cluster four the green cluster and these
are the ten or so genes that are highly
expressed in cluster four so you're able
to look at any individual cell cluster
and I understand what is the gene
expression within that cluster now to
show you what it looks like in our
software our software really does a good
job of making this super user-friendly
from sort of a GUI interface so you can
see here on the right column you have
your eight clusters you can select or
deselect them and on the bottom you can
see the genes per cluster that they give
you sort of the p-value of each gene in
a given cluster and you can also mess at
the top with the spot opacity so you
could take away the spots or you could
include the spots depending on
so the visualization you like to see on
the tissue section but kind of moving
even further in the software you can
zoom and get really kind of high
resolution understanding of the local
region within the brain and here we've
zoomed in to the top left portion you
can really resolve what those spots look
like and what spots cluster with what
you know which population in this
example here now you might be interested
in one specific gene and in this example
we show with the mouse brain that there
are two genes and in particular
TMS b4x and Salina that are expressed in
the hippocampus and so we knew via
literature that these two genes would be
highly expressed in the hippocampus and
you can see that with spatial when we
select these two that they are indeed
confirmed in that anatomical region of
interest and what's nice about this is
it sort of provides a positive control
you know so if you're ever in doubt that
you know you're identifying a gene in a
region that's very interesting and you
don't know whether it's true or not you
could always look at a game that is
anatomically rub relevant and making
sure that it actually does locate in the
vicinity of where it should be to give
you a kind of a positive control
reinforcement that what you're seeing is
true and so you can actually identify
and zoom into those regions and confirm
that these genes are highly expressed
and in the software this is what it
looks like you can change at the bottom
right your color scheme as well to make
it easier to visualize but this gives
you an example of SPI and k-8 and DDI
t4l which are genes that are expressed
in the brain tissue but in different
regions and just gives you another idea
of how you can look at individual genes
on this tissue
the last feature which is incredibly
impactful is the ability to look at
anatomical investigation so you might
have been familiar with other
technologies that allow you to look at
regions of interest within the text
tissue section this software tool allows
you to do that on the on the backside in
the software analysis so you've got in
gene expression globally of the tissue
but you may only be interested in let's
say the top right region maybe that was
deemed by a pathologist as cancerous and
you want to say hey what are the genes
in that region I don't want to look at
it based off an unbiased gene expression
and clustering I want to look at it
based on the bias that I have in that we
believe that that Anatomy is important
for our biology so there's a feature
that allows you to sort of select
without sort of you know predefined
geometries what area you're interested
in and then again pull out at the bottom
the genes in that specific area that are
of interest and we think that this tool
will certainly be of interest to a lot
of the users that we've talked to that
are eager to try this technology and
just to give you a sense of other places
where this is used since you know
neuroscience is one field but also in
cancer and this is probably one of the
more impactful studies that has been
done with spatial gene expression where
this group Berglund at all in nature in
2018 wanted to look at prostate cancer
sections and ask pathologists two
questions of okay can you annotate where
on
this prostate cancer tissue there is
cancer versus sort of stroma and the pin
glands and then we're going to take this
through gene expression workflow and
assign six genes that we will call
factor signatures that are highly
expressed in cancer and will perform for
the heatmap analysis of where those
genes are upregulated on the spatial
tissue and when they did this they saw
two scenarios that came up frequently
and the top scenario you see that the
pathologist annotated a region of
interest with cancer and kind
the land and in the factor activity map
actually got pretty good confirmation
that there is cancer in that region
based off of those six genes as you can
see in the heat map in the top as well
as sort of a positive control that
stroma existed in the regions that are
outside of that area on the far right
but in the bottom case which is
incredibly profound is that the
pathologist did not annotate this H&E
section as being cancers but when
spatial gene expression was formed
performed and looked at those six genes
you can see that cancer was highly
prevalent based off of gene expression
in that area now this obviously needs to
be followed up as you know there are two
readouts that say differing things and
probably need another orthogonal means
to validate these but what it does is it
shows you that two dimensions might
inform you better than the one and it
also informs you that maybe you are
missing things if you don't perform a
spatial gene expression analysis on a
tissue section so we think that this is
going to be really impactful again in
oncology as well as in the pathology
space there's another example that was
pretty impactful from maniatis at all in
2019 which studied ALS and what they did
is they looked at mouse spinal cords
over the course of a disease model of a
list but then they also correlate it to
human spinal cords postmortem from
actual ALS tissues patients and what
they wanted to know is is there
something interesting about the
interaction of these cells in pre and
post ALS onset of symptoms so in the
mouse models you can imagine that before
even witnessing symptoms you are able to
resect these spinal cords and look at
them and also post as well as the post
human brains of who postmortem ALS
spinal cord tissue and what they found
in general using only really spatial
analysis is that they could look at
really define local regions in which the
microglia underwent some sort of
dysfunction that really was before what
would consider an astro glial
dysfunction which is usually indicative
of symptoms in ALS and they found that
these are very proximal to the motor
neurons indicating that that actually
precedes the kind of the the the symptom
the negative symptoms that you
experience in sort of the motor function
and so without the spatial they weren't
able to know sort of how these cells
interact with one another and how they
collate co-locate with one another but
what they might have actually found is
sort of more of a predictive biomarkers
that occurs in microglial cells way
prior to the onset of some of the
traditional symptomatic conditions that
most people are looking for
and sort of lastly a great example and
we believe that a lot of our sort of
current single-cell researchers are
really looking forward to using spatial
for is this idea of looking at
single-cell information and spatial
information at the same time so in the
top here you can see that this group out
of side life has looked at a
developmental heart tissue and done a
dissociation on it to look at the single
cell gene expression and clusters all
based off those gene expression to kind
of understand what are those major
anatomical regions based on single cell
information but then on the bottom they
also did in parallel tissue sectioning
on these developmental hard coast
sections and clustered the spatial
transcriptomic data in a similar matter
and then they merge the data types so
they said they want the resolution of
the single cell but merge to correlate
with the gene expression of the spatial
data what they did were able to do then
is trace single cells back to their
spatial position and then actually
three-dimensionally render the IMP the
heart back into sort of a larger gross
model and so we believe that many people
are working towards sort of these 3d
molecular atlases in this case it was
the developing human heart but we've
seen cases where people are interested
in doing embryos brain and spinal cord
as well as you know even if intestines
and we think that really spatial is the
tool that will exist to really for these
sort of human cell outlets or human
tumor Atlas projects that are really
going to kind of accelerate as a result
of these findings
so lastly you know we are hopefully in
convinced you that you know this is
going to be able to allow you to
envision your dimensions by pairing gene
expression morphology and protein with
fresh frozen tissue samples and we
believe that you know this is sort of a
more rapid robust streamlined workflow
that can be easily implemented in sort
of a typical lab and if the
infrastructure doesn't exist there are
places that easily kind of provide these
as services that will enable most
researchers to uses and the pre-order
for this solution is available today you
can go on our website at 10x genomics
comm slash spatial and look up for more
information we are hoping to ship this
product later this fall closer to the
end of October early November timeframe
but get your orders in today if you're
interested and just so everybody is
aware you know we have a pretty large
and growing single-cell portfolio and
now we have a spatial portfolio and gene
expression is sort of our first
application but we do envision that we
will include more applications in the
future and we're eager to hear what are
the applications in which you are
interested in to kind of take advantage
of the technology moving forward so stay
tuned for that we do have a nice roadmap
on the spatial side up that is in
progress today so with that I'm happy to
take more questions after this
presentation via email and I'll try to
get back to you as soon as I can thank
you very much